the war in Sudan between the Sudanese
Army and the paramilitary rapid support
forces has entered its 100th day with no
sight so far having been able to achieve
a major and decisive victory over the
other and with huge humanitarian
consequences hundreds of thousands of
people have fled from the capital hartum
alone seeking refuge in neighboring
states or neighboring countries as the
two wearing sites battled each other in
residential neighborhoods here in the
capital Khartoum homes and properties
have been destroyed as the two sides
exchange gunfire and heavy artillery and
due to air strikes being launched by the
Sudanese Army markets and factories that
used to supply the entire nation have
been burned to the ground leading to a
humanitarian crisis and to a food crisis
in the country now the war has also
spread to other parts of the country
including the fragile western region of
Darfur in ginena in West Darfur hundreds
of thousands of people have fled to
neighboring Chad as militias Allied to
the parent military rapid support forces
targeted People based on their
ethnicities according to accounts of
refugees who arrived in Chad fleeing
from the violence in Janina in westar4
the United Nations says at least 3 000
people have been killed since the start
of the fighting and More Than 3 million
people displaced but it also says that
that figure is likely an undercount of
the real number of those who've been
killed and those who fled from the
fighting here in hartum now diplomatic
efforts have been made to try to get the
two wearing sides to end the fighting
but so far that has failed to achieve
any concrete and